so GB news spent days promoting a
supposedly Blockbuster incredible
groundbreaking interview with Donald
Trump conducted by British politician
and broadcaster Nigel farage and I have
to tell you this is one of the most
Bonkers Off the Wall interviews I've
ever seen Trump do it's essentially 100
an interview about cultural issues like
cancel culture and what does Trump think
about Meghan Markle and T fund black
lives matter comes up in this first clip
and even right off the bat here Trump
jumping right into police related stuff
which is just crazy because police were
attacked by his supporters on January
6th no mention or support of those
officers but plenty of mentions of it
was actually antifa and BLM who did bad
stuff take a look at this just off the
wall alternate reality
now either way we've got Biden and
Harris in office and they've got
plummeting poll ratings and we've got a
border crisis as you quite rightly said
remember Plum everything here is sort of
a lie plummeting poll readings still
higher than Trump and the Border crisis
where essentially nothing has really
changed since Trump left uh Law and
Order
um the black lives matter movement which
is now becoming increasingly I think
political don't you well it's shocking
that it started off you know with pigs
in a blanket right you know that right
you know the expression frame like bacon
and they were I was about our police our
great police and all of us the great
police where Trump doesn't say anything
about the police that were tased and Etc
on January 6 by his supporters this
becomes mainstream I don't really think
so and uh antifa bad very bad bad and
they had antifa in that rally they had
antifa leading a lot of people on that
day on January no evidence of that
whatsoever
and I will say that uh it's pretty
incredible that nothing happens to them
but the other side this has been going
on for many years there is no evidence
that antifa individuals committed crimes
on January 6th that's why there are no
cases against them they're not just
about racial equality though well I
think they're about politics but I think
they're about a lot of other things if
you go back to their original founding
of what they were saying kill the police
what they're saying is kill the police
and that becomes mainstream not good not
good says Donald Trump next clip
um Donald Trump claims that now we
aren't globally respected anymore we
have objective data about that the U.S
reputation was lower than ever under
trump it has now recovered to some
degree under Biden is Biden perfect no
is his foreign policy the stuff of
Dreams no but by every measure the U.S
is more respected now than under Trump
but Trump doesn't care but Biden G7
Biden turns up with the G7 and this was
before he let everybody down in
Afghanistan and and which which leaves
us wondering where is America in the
world now I mean we've got big threats
haven't we we've got a lot of Russian
troops on the Ukrainian border we've got
China China ever more bellicose in their
statements about Taiwan we've got Iran I
mean can you believe it negotiations are
going on this week with Iran and the
Israelis are very very scared where is
America in the world right now I think
it's at the lowest point it's ever been
at there is no objective way to defend
that statement it is objectively a lie I
don't think it's ever been in a position
like this we're not respected anymore I
will tell you there were no planes
flying over Taiwan and the the name
wasn't even mentioned you didn't talk
about Taiwan when I was President it
wasn't going to happen what they're
doing now Trump knows nothing about
Taiwan that's why he wasn't talking
about it and then wait till after the
Olympics I assume and perhaps something
will happen but it's not good if you're
there and you have bombers flying over
your so Trump just wrong there is the
the reputation of the U.S has started to
recover it's not perfect it's not
perfect but it is start it was at the
bottom under Trump where Trump wasn't
even party to many important Global
discussions including on climate as
we've mentioned before
um okay next clip in this one Trump says
something let's let's see if we can
figure out what it is even that Trump is
saying here I'm not a fan of hers at all
this is the Meghan Markle clip in this
clip Trump says he's not a fan of Meghan
Markle okay
I'm not a fan of hers at all and I think
she's very disrespectful to the queen
that we just spoke about who's such a
great woman who's such a great person
right a historic person I think she's
very disrespectful to the royal family
but maybe most importantly to the queen
and what's wild about this is you know
Meghan Markle and her husband one of the
princes I don't I don't care about the
Royals they made a decision together
right I mean about separating from the
kind of traditional life of the royal
family but Trump's not a fan of Meghan
Markle specifically kind of just all
very weird then here's the strange clip
Trump says something was a big mistake
let's see if we can figure out what it
is that Trump says was a big mistake
I heard you through I guess through
Twitter
um it was was for you you know something
that you used a massive effect oh Jack
Dorsey is being removed as CEO of
Twitter because of shareholder pressure
but whether that means they'll improve
uh as a Channel or not when I was amazed
the day that the Taliban you mentioned
Afghanistan a moment ago the day the
Taliban took over Kabul I did put out a
message that said it seemed ridiculous
that their leadership was still active
on Twitter
and yet you were still bad well they
were wrong and what they did and were
dealing with the United States President
who's obviously a popular so when he
says they were wrong is he talking about
the Taliban or Twitter like it's not
totally clear to me president from based
on everything that you see and and uh
them and Facebook and I think they made
a big mistake I think if they had it
today okay I guess he's saying if
Twitter and Facebook had a do-over about
banning him I think over again they
wouldn't be doing it uh we are uh you
know we get the voice out we have to do
it we have a an obligation to do that
but he's leaving I guess it was probably
enforced because they're down and also
there's no excitement on Twitter anymore
okay so I guess he's saying Jack Dorsey
is leaving because Twitter isn't doing
so well it's all just very you know what
what are you talking about dude uh Trump
is asked about 2024 he seems to be
signaling that he is running why on
Earth would he consider going back into
that hell again so I love our country
I brought the country to a level it's
never seen before right then we had
covet come in and then I brought it back
came up with vaccines that you're using
we're all using the world is using saved
tens of millions of people throughout
the world so now he's for the vaccines
in less than nine months it was supposed
to take 12 years now it was never
supposed to take 12 years we knew from
the start these vaccines would be based
on an mRNA platform the platform had
been researched for decades nobody
thought what Trump is saying is there
are times in history where the
development of some vaccines could take
10 to 12 years often six to eight nobody
ever thought it was going to take 12
years with the MRNA vaccines just heard
the other day they're expecting it to
take 12 years and everyone said it
wasn't going to work and they work
incredibly well we've done an amazing
job if you love The Country you have no
choice it's not a question it's just
this is a wonderful beautiful life
but I like that too because I was
helping people that's why I did it and
uh I think you'll be happy in the future
too so Trump again with this idea of if
you love The Country you gotta run and I
think you're going to be happy in the
future he seems to be signaling he's
going to be running and then finally no
Trump interview is complete without
Trump bragging about the size of his
crowds so looking ahead
you know from here
is the message to look back on November
2020 and to condemn and criticize much
of what happened or is the message to
look forward and try and make sure that
that that that weakness in the system
can't exist I think it's both I think it
has to be both we have a base in Alabama
as an example at 69 000 people recently
show up wherever I go we get I think I'm
getting bigger crowds now at the rallies
and you know the rest because you've
been to plenty of them I have the
biggest crowds I've ever had when he
says now by the way he had when he
hasn't done a rally in months and months
and months so a wacky wacky interview
but the big takeaways Trump's still
bragging about the same stuff without
any basis and he seems to be leaning
towards running in 2024. one of our
sponsors is splendidspoon now if you're
like me I love planning my meals out for
the week but sometimes I just run out of
time to plan them for every single day
and Splendid spoon makes that whole
process a lot easier they deliver fresh
delicious plant-based meals right to
your door ready to eat no cooking no
cleaning dishes saves you a lot of time
you can choose from over 50 hot and cold
meal options there's smoothies grain and
noodle bowls soups I'm a big soup guy
many of you know that I also really
liked the vegan meatballs with marinara
noodles delicious both eye and Splendid
spoon believe eating more plant-based is
a great tool for feeling good for
helping the environment the list goes on
I'm not vegan you all know that I think
but Splendid spoon is really great to
just help me maximize the proportion of
plants in my diet Splendid spoon takes
all of the work out of tasty healthy
plant-based meals and you'll save 35
dollars when you go to splendidspoon.com
Pacman the link is down below